I don't want to brag and this isn't to
brag but way back in the 1900s I hosted
the definitive MTV dating show
singled-out exam they tried to recapture
the magic or other matchmaking formats
the only one that's come close to the
mid-2000s gem next the most hilarious
part of the show is the contestant files
which have been cataloged by New York
comic Lane more on her amazing Instagram
the hotties of MTV's next I'm going to
show you a completely real bio from one
of the Hardy Boys of Next and for 250
points you're going to have to make up
another fun fact about them first up
here's Kyle now these nickname nugget
love Jana Montana and cries all the time
all the time all the time all the time
hahaha what's his next back Nikki now
goes by Nick Swardson
very yes
I was going to say he got herpes from
his first kiss
from his dad alright boys some love
Hannah Montana hates Miley Cyrus all
right next up meet Holly here's Holly
she's 19 she's nicknamed Gump she's
failed her driving test four times and
burps and farts while eating limes
conveniens what's the next pack piggy
smokes well pregnant till she is not all
right boy Nick poison doesn't know how
to spell Holly except hey this is honey
he's a Pratt mama's boy he wants to
start his own line hey business he
prefers to date girls with fake boobs
what else makes words and coin the
phrase what happens in Reno stays in
reading
so
the necklace opens a Stargate and then I
then decided it that is the map to the
Stargate except here's Janet she speaks
Russian fluently lives with 11 girls and
held a dead snake for a day to overcome
her fear
what's another fun fact about Janet Tom
she's our Kelly's favorite
[Applause]
miji uh her dad once convinced her his
penis
you